while speaking of Jordan don't burn this
book how am I doing here with glare
forward by Jordan Peterson so I want to
tell you a little bit of insider stuff
and I'll I'll tell you a little bit
about the book itself but Jordan when we
were in Oslo we were doing a second show
in Oslo and most of the shows sold out
in ours some of them sold out in minutes
I think the Stockholm shows sold out so
quickly that they added another show cuz
it sold out in like three minutes or
something we were in Oslo and I got the
call from my from my agent at CAA we had
we had been trying to figure out a book
deal and a bunch of people had reached
out to us and then if you made some of
you guys were may remember about a year
ago there was this Playboy profile on me
which was really good and then from
there basically every publishing house
was reaching out and they wanted to
figure it out and we went back and forth
and then my guys at CAA basically put
the book up for auction which is where
all the publishing houses come in they
just make their best offer anyway my
agent calls me he said we closed the
deal this is what we're doing I was
beyond overjoyed I ran into Jordans
dressing room so I'm in a little little
dressing room on the side Jordan's got
the nice big dressing room and he was in
there with his wife Tammy and oh and
David my husband was with me at the time
so we walked in there and we were we
were just absolutely thrilled and I told
Jordan this is about ten minutes before
the show so he's about to speak to you
know 4,000 some odd people the shows in
in Oslo were huge and I told him and he
slapped his hands together and he had
this huge huge smile on his face and he
kind of spun around in his chair and he
was absolutely just just thrilled for me
and without before I could even say
anything he said he said would you like
me to write the foreword for you and I
was like like how do you even respond to
that like now that I'm good Peterson no
foreword that'll be fine